apuntando a la plataforma de misiles en
yemen que los rebeldes hutíes habrían
usado para atacar emiratos árabes
unidos- desde abu dhabi el ministerio de
defensa publicó este vídeo en el que
muestra la destrucción del sitio de
lanzamiento unas horas después de
anunciar que interceptaron un tercer
misil ucci en dos semanas el último
intento de ataque en la noche del
domingo se produjo en medio de la
primera visita de un presidente israelí
a los emiratos horas antes isaac herzog
condenó los recientes ataques contra el
país del golfo llevados a cabo por los
rebeldes hutíes apoyados por irán
condenamos en todas las formas cualquier
ataque a su soberanía por parte de
grupos terroristas
y estamos aquí juntos para encontrar
formas y medios para aportar la máxima
seguridad a los pueblos que buscan la
paz en nuestra región los emiratos
forman parte de la coalición liderada
por arabia saudita que lleva 7 años
luchando contra los útiles de yemen un
conflicto en gran medida considerado
como una guerra indirecta entre arabia
saudita e irán los misiles de los útiles
llevan mucho tiempo apuntando hacia
arabia saudita pero este mes golpearon
por primera vez a los emiratos
amenazando su reputación de esta
habilidad emiratos árabes unidos- se
convirtió en la primera nación árabe en
normalizar sus lazos con israel en
virtud de un acuerdo negociado por eeuu
en 2020 a pesar del ataque con misiles
la visita del presidente israelí
continuó como estaba previsto en medio
de un refuerzo de seguridad